[Music]
[Applause]
ross tucker he went to princeton he's
happy to tell you about it cbs westwood
one color analyst host of the ross
tucker football podcast how often do you
remind people you went to princeton ross
i mean almost never why are you taking
shots i don't know bring me on i don't
know come on what what did i do to
dessert i don't know i'm under the
weather
i'm i'm under the weather and i'm mad
and i'm i want to lash out at somebody
and i lash out at fritzy all the time
and and so you you just you popped up on
the screen and i have to yell at you
well i hope you feel better i've been
watching this week i saw the hat and
everything um i'm you're you're a
a warrior for doing the show all week
even though you haven't been feeling
great i'll say this dan in all sincerity
people bring up the princeton thing all
the time it's not me it's like
people have like a little bit of like a
inferiority or insecurity thing about it
i don't know i don't bring it up
it's not relevant to the nfl or even
college nobody asked me about princeton
football so it's not but people always
bring it up somehow but
people expect you to be smarter
right
i think that's fair yeah it's it's like
eight years in a row it's number one
school in the country the reality is and
you know this
um football absolutely helped
with uh me getting accepted there in
fact dan i never told you before the
valedictorian of my high school
my year
had 1550 s.a.t.s
back when they were really hard
he did not get into harvard or princeton
i got into both and let me just tell you
my sats and my class rank were lower
lower than his it was bad i mean i saw
him i saw him in the hallways all he
ever wanted to do
was go to harvard or princeton and all i
wanted to do dan was play football at
penn state so i told him i saw him in
the hallway listen man when you were
fooling around studying i was lifting
weights trying to get in the best
colleges
wow
sure that made him feel better
oh he went to columbia or penn he's a
doctor it doesn't make a difference he's
i'm sure he's doing great
all right your reaction to the nfl
schedule release is there
one thing that stood out more than
anything else
well two things stood out to me number
one the fact that they made it like a
10-day mini series dan is just hilarious
i mean it's you know they started last
week with the international game
announcement then they had the initial
amazon game announcement then they had i
mean it's unreal
what they've made this into and guess
what we all feed into it yeah i'm wrong
with it we all eat it up yeah you know
they're they were giving standalone
games by releasing it that way
and
8 45 in the morning and they're giving
me the thursday night amazon game i'm
like all right
you know what they should do you know
would be amazing next year
announced the schedule one team at a
time
so like they announced the jet schedule
and patriots fans know two of their
games then they announced the dolphin
schedule and and patriots fans know four
of their games like and people are
putting together and then there's leaks
like uh it's unbelievable how much
intrigue there is to it that's one thing
that jumped out to me uh the other thing
that jumped out which i think is just
interesting yeah week two they have a
monday night football double header
but there's an hour and a half overlap
so dan you know my favorite team i
played for was the buffalo bills i say
it all to i love playing for the bills i
played for five teams that was my
favorite they they host the titans at 7
15.
at 8 30
the eagles host the vikings you know i
do the eagles preseason games on tv i do
their pre-game on the radio so i watch
them they've got like the two teams i
watched the closest
overlapping in quote unquote standalone
games
they've never done it before i just
talked to michael north from the nfl
on the ross tucker podcast he said they
might try three different kinds of
double headers next year it's a little
bit weird but they're they're
experimenting they're trying something
different
we're talking to ross tucker he went to
princeton and former nfl lineman host of
the ross tucker football podcast
who's the bengals this year
such a good question i think they'll be
good
i'm not sure they're the favorite in the
afc north
i think the ravens are going to come
back with a vengeance
not how are the bengals going to be who
will be this year's bengals
oh oh oh oh i thought since the bengals
had five prime time games you were like
doing an existential question of like
who are they
are they worthy of that um oh this
year's bengals
that's a good question
do the broncos count sure is that unfair
no
i mean okay then probably the broncos i
was
i was going to say the eagles
you know what i can see the eagles being
very good i really can i mean they're so
good up front
both sides of the ball look at their
schedule which i'm not a big believer in
oh they have an easy stretch or a tough
stretch because it evens out
but they really have a great chance to
get off to a great start
it's hurt second full year as a starter
they have aj brown
the nfc east is not that tough i think
the cowboys will be down
and i think the nfc in general as a
conference is a lot more winnable than
the afc so yeah i think a surprise i
think that'd be a really nice surprise
super bowl pick is the eagles but if i
say that i'm a homer you can say that i
can't
the team that's overrated
probably still the packers in my mind i
see a lot of people
talking about the packers going to the
super bowl that they couldn't go to the
super bowl when they had the best
receiver in the nfl
now they're going to go without them
i mean i
i don't really see that happening i i
think that they will lose a playoff game
like they seemingly do every year
i'm not feeling the packers getting to
the super bowl i just think you lose a
guy like devante adams
i think it i think
there's a vibe i think i think it hurts
the locker room did you see all the
titans players
how upset they were when the team traded
aj brown well so was the coach exclusive
to winning mike vrabel did his best
acting when he had that press conference
talk about losing aj brown it's like uh
you know i understand what management's
doing like uh
okay
good for you
it's awkward dan and i look i don't i
think john robinson and mike brabel get
along great
but if things start to go south there
you know fully well
raibl's going to say
oh really ownership
amy adams strunk it wasn't my idea to
move on from aj brown for monetary
reasons plus frable had just come out
three weeks earlier and said that they
would not trade aj brown as long as he
was the coach
rabel's a former player we were
teammates in new england he knows that's
a bad look for him you know you say
something publicly like that and then go
against that it's not a good look
the
underdog the most
underappreciated team going into this
season will be
um
i think the ravens i think the ravens
you know because of how they finished
last year
because they trade hollywood brown and
they have quote unquote no receivers
i don't think people realize how good
they have a chance to be
they were absolutely
decimated
by injuries last year lamar obviously
didn't play at the end of the season i
think the ravens come back with a
vengeance i think there's a great chance
they win that division
i'm curious about the cleveland browns
with deshaun watson and
when he plays how much he's going to
play does he get punished at all this
year
feels like these trials these cases are
not going to be heard until after this
upcoming season i don't know if the nfl
is proactive on something like this
or they
and is that a reason why the cleveland
browns could be holding on to baker
mayfield a little bit longer that
if deshawn is going to be suspended for
six eight games well if you look at the
brown schedule dan and this is what
people do and i do it as well to try to
read the tea leaves
they didn't give the browns a whole lot
of prime time games and they didn't give
the browns prime time games early i
think it's bad for business i i think
whether he's suspended or not
it's bad for business
to have desean watson while these
legal cases are hanging over his head
in prime time
you know everything they do
it makes me laugh
about all the fan bases that are all
upset the nfl hates them
you know this the whole thing is to
maximize ratings this is a business
they're maximizing they don't care about
you they don't hate your team any more
than they like some other team they like
ratings but they also don't like bad pr
which is why i think they're trying to
hide to sean watson and the browns as
much as possible i don't think they see
the value look jerry jones probably says
to him put the browns on every week
people will be complaining about it and
any publicity is good publicity nfl
doesn't see it that way and i think
their schedule and the lack of prime
time games for the browns pretty good
indicator because they're probably the
best team
to have the fewest amount of prime time
games if tom brady former teammate
asked for
advice that he's going to go into the
broadcasting booth
at some point next couple of years what
would you tell brady
yeah really simple
make sure you're having fun
he's so intense i am not worried about
him from a preparation standpoint at all
he's the biggest psycho i've ever been
around i mean that as a compliment like
he will be crazy prepared
but
can he just enjoy himself you know i
like romo a lot
because i like broadcasters dan that i
can tell they love it i can tell having
fun it's the reason why your show is so
successful
everybody can tell that you guys and the
danettes you're having a great time
that's i mean that's what it's supposed
to be
i can tell romo's having a blast there
are other guys
i'm not always sure if they love
football i'm not sure if they're having
a really good time doing it
i don't know if brady's going to be able
to do that i think he's going to be so
intense
about the information and wanting to do
well
i don't know if he'll be able to loosen
up
and relax and really enjoy it and i
think it's hard to really be good
if you're not enjoying that needs to
come across i think it's bananas that he
got that much money
without ever having done it before it's
one thing for romo after he proved
himself it's nothing for aikman after he
proved himself to give tom that much
money when he might stink you know he
might not be good at it is really an
interesting decision
and you can over prepare and having work
with analysts
you know you tell them
just cut it in half
because you get so consumed with i got
to know everything it's it was my
approach when i hosted the olympics for
the first time i thought i had to know
everything about everything
and then i realized as a result i didn't
know anything about anything because i
was just my mind was so full of stats
and countries and stars and events
and i talked to al michaels and he gave
me the greatest advice that i ever
received with the olympics he said dan
my man
half hour at a time
know what you need to know the next half
hour and then the next half hour
instead of
kind of piling on and saying i know
everything
and then i didn't use 97 of that stuff
and that's what i'm wondering about
brady that does he just dive in because
he has to people expect that and then
can you come off naturally
and still have all that information and
i think that's going to be the trick for
tom is
can he have romo-like moments
where he seems downright giddy that this
team is doing this in this moment
and that result
so so dan what's so fascinating about
tom is
his public persona
and social media presence are like a
total 180. you know he's so buttoned up
in every press conference or interview
he ever does right almost robotic
but yet his social media
is amazing so any and i'm sure it's
somebody else's ideas but his social
media is amazing he's got to be
somewhere in between those two he's got
to be
relaxed it's like when i whenever i fill
in for you the first couple of times dan
i had all kinds of notes and then like
five minutes in it's a meet friday and
paulie asked me what mustard i wanted to
i wanted the next thing i know it's noon
and i'm putting sausage i'm putting
brats in my cup for the drive home like
i i mean i don't even i don't even have
notes when i fill in for you anymore
it's unbelievable because it just it
happens so much more naturally if when
you just engage with the guys well
paulie would suggest you had a couple of
notes next time you did
it just like four or five just just a
couple of notes there jumping off points
yeah that's all yeah just a couple of
notes that's all uh hey it's great to
talk to you as always thanks for joining
us and uh thanks for all the input that
you uh provide for us of course my
pleasure feel better thank you for
having me dan that's ross tucker he went
to princeton cbs westwood one color
analyst